[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show the
alleged gunman in the Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in Florida
reportedly wants to give any inheritance
that he is due from his late mother's
estate to the victims families or an
organization that will help the
community heal according to his
attorneys yesterday he appeared at a
Broward County Circuit Court in Fort
Lauderdale to determine whether he's
indigent or whether he stands to collect
$800,000 from his late mother's estate
and other financial accounts in his name
which would mean that he is not indigent
and this is sort of a determination in
terms of a legal representation that
he's going to get and it determines a
couple elements of how the case against
him is going to proceed before it was
determined that he couldn't afford his
own attorney and he was appointed a
public defender and now they're trying
to figure out well if he has this money
coming to him then the public defender
should actually be dismissed and he
should be forced to hire an actual
private attorney and pay that attorney
and what is being said by his current
court-appointed attorney is that the
alleged shooter doesn't want the money
he wants the money to go to the victims
families and then presumably he would be
indigent because he wouldn't be getting
the money and he would get to keep his
court-appointed attorney this is kind of
interesting to me Pat because I mean I
want to be clear public defenders are
doing something that is very very
important but they are not always the
best attorneys in terms of the resources
and training that they can provide to
clients so it's generally considered and
part of it is just being overworked and
having an insane number of cases they're
working on at one time it's generally
considered that having a private
attorney if you can afford one is going
to afford you a better defense than
having a public defender but it seems
that he's sort of manipulating the
situation
to try to keep the public defender and
again somebody who's willing to commit
allegedly commit an act like this may
not be someone who's going to think most
rationally about anything but it is an
unusual situation right I do wonder why
he would choose a public defender over a
private the defender if he can afford
one especially because it seems like the
private defender would be able to offer
more time to the shooter and the guys up
against the death penalty so you'd have
to imagine he wants to keep his life to
serve the rest of his sentence until he
dies at an old age but you never really
know I guess and I think that it is an
interesting choice I wonder if it's the
sign of remorse that he's showing by
offering the money to the victims
instead of keeping it for himself
obviously if he's going to live the rest
of his life in prison it's not like he
can really use that money to a great
extent so I think I think it's an
interesting story at least there's a
couple different elements that you could
point to right one is is the idea of the
donation something that he came up with
or something his public defender came up
with is the idea of the donation
potentially to curry favor to avoid the
death penalty and maybe get life in
prison is there someone else who has
influenced him when it comes to this
possibility of the donation and then the
at the end of it it's once again if we
imagine what it takes for someone to
commit such a heinous act
can we really apply sort of what our
logic would be to what they are doing I
don't really know that we can right and
Nicholas Cruz the shooter did seem to be
a little bit remorseful the day of the
shooting even if you just watched like
his arraignment and you know thinking
look at the footage he did seem a little
bit sad about it which is interesting
because obviously the decision to go on
a shooting spree at a school wasn't a
spur-of-the-moment decision I'm sure he
planned it for a long time and after the
shooting many of the students at
Parkland said that they suspected it was
Cruz because he just exhibited signs of
that for many years but I guess you know
after committing the shooting maybe he
did have a change of heart
because then you're actually seeing the
ramifications of your actions so I think
he could have you know had a change
obviously he has to pay a penalty for it
and I think that that penalty should be
serving the rest of his life in prison
that's probably going to be the result
regardless of if he has a public
defender or private defender but maybe
he will get that death penalty it is
Florida after all what you're saying
about maybe regretting what he is
accused of doing right after the
shooting is interesting we know that
with a lot of these premeditated actions
that often connect to sort of emotional
disturbance including suicide attempts
that it's very common for example with
suicide attempts I recently read an
interesting article about this that very
often for bridge jumpers who survive
many of them say the instant that I let
go I realized I wanted to live and of
course not all of them do some of them
do and then it turns their life around
and they become you know suicide
prevention activists or whatever the
case may be it's probably similar not
that mass shootings and suicide are in
any way analogous but I would not be at
all surprised if the moment that a
shooter starts doing a shooting they
changed their mind and I all or realized
that it was a mistake and I also
wouldn't be surprised if they end up
taking their own lives because of that
realization we talk about these
murder-suicide things where it sort of
presumed that the shooter goes in
planning to also take their own life
maybe they don't always but it's that
regret that hits the second day open
fire where they say I can no longer live
with myself and that's why they take
their own life and their own lives in
the shooting yeah it probably depends on
the shooter but another angle I want to
touch on too is do you feel comfortable
talking about this story even because I
remember after the Parkland shooting we
deliberately chose not to say the name
of the shooter because you know there's
this idea that shooters could be
inspired by the attention that they get
sometimes posthumously even by the media
after they go on these sprees and kill a
lot of people but I mean there are so
few mass shooters out there and I think
we have to get a sense of what is going
on inside their heads and so the only
really way to do that is by
looking into the specific shooters so I
mean it's like you're solving one
problem we're trying to solve one
problem but perhaps you're creating
another and causing more mass shootings
indirectly I don't know yeah I don't
know I don't know either but we'll see
ultimately what happens with the
attorney we'll see what happens with
these supposed planned donations I've
been talking for a while about how
studies on diet and exercise show that
just mathematically speaking diet is
much more responsible for weight loss
than is exercise and what I mean
mathematically is that you can much more
easily reduce net calories by reducing
the calories that you eat then you can
work off calories by exercising and sort
of if you imagine how long do you have
to exercise to burn 200 calories versus
how easily can you avoid eating 200
calories worth of food right so we've
known that for a while but there's an
interesting new study published in
diabetes magazine or the journal
diabetes which involved animals but it
appears as though it could also be
applied to exercise in humans and what
the study looked at is exercise and
weight loss among people and animals and
what it found was that exercise in and
of itself is not an effective way to
lose weight but it doesn't mean what I
said in terms of the balance between
diet and exercise what it points out is
that in most experiments that were done
participants lost less weight than would
have been expected mathematically given
the number of calories they were burning
in their workouts so it's sort of hard
to separate this from what I said before
about you can much more easily avoid
eating 200 calories than you can burn
200 calories what the study found is
even when burning 200 calories by
exercising the amount of weight that we
would anticipate would be lost by
burning the 200 calories seems to be
smaller than the amount of weight not
gained or lost by avoiding the
consumption of too
calories I really don't know Pat whether
I'm doing a good job of explaining this
but I think the idea is that diet is an
incredibly important part of weight loss
and that exercise is important for
fitness but that is a weight loss tool
it is not as important as some people
make it out to be yeah and I think the
thing is after you exercise you often
get hungry too so say you burn off 200
calories you're gonna be starving
afterwards and so you'll probably eat
something that could surpass 200
calories and then you know you didn't
really lose any weight after that and
the other reason too is I mean if you it
let's say you go on like a two-mile run
or something like that you may get sore
you're probably gonna be sedentary
afterwards so you may decide to just
chill out for the rest of the day and
watch television instead of like going
for a walk or doing things that would
also burn calories just at a slower rate
so I think that in part has to do with
why exercise isn't as efficient
obviously you know there are there are
some benefits when it comes to weight
loss and exercise like I think it does
speed up your metabolism but if you're
just going for pure weight loss alone
the most effective and the easiest thing
really is just to eat less and you know
that can be hard for some people
certainly yeah so I mean I guess that
would be other than going out and
exercising I I don't know if everybody
would agree that the easy thing to do is
to just eat less I mean I think a lot of
people definitely struggle with that but
I think that your point about the sort
of relative efficiency of it is one that
has been replicated in study after study
I mean it have you ever seen ever run on
a treadmill and you should go for like a
two-mile run or something and you see
the amount of calories you burned it's
probably something like 200 to 250
calories that can be pretty daunting to
people because 250 calories is like a
bag of potato chips you know it's it's
not that much food so I think someone
who's trying to lose weight could go for
that two-mile run on a treadmill exert
all this energy try so hard to get there
and then they think wow that that's all
I burned 200 calories that's like the
amount of a granola bar or something and
then yeah they could lose interest and
be demoralized and not try as much
anymore well to segue from diet to
cannabis which can sometimes make people
very very hung
I want to talk about former Speaker of
the House John Boehner John Boehner was
Speaker of the House from 2011 to 2015
and he has changed his view on Marable
legalization he said yesterday on
Twitter that where he follows me by the
way that my thinking on cannabis has
evolved he previously said many many
times that he was completely opposed to
the legalization of marijuana and now he
says that he has a different view that
it is time for a shift in federal
marijuana policy he believes that
cannabis needs to be D scheduled meaning
not scheduled as a Schedule one drug so
that research can be done veterans can
be helped we can deal with we have a
number of studies that show that
cannabis legalization is hugely
beneficial when dealing with the opioid
epidemic so this is I mean listen
Boehner was I saw Boehner more of a as a
pragmatist than an ideologue now I don't
mean that he wasn't an ideological right
winger but what I mean is that I always
felt that part of his being an
ideological right winger was political
posturing rather than his personally and
sincerely held beliefs that doesn't make
them any better they are just as
damaging when a politician says they're
anti gay to raise money rather than
because they actually are anti-gay it's
not really any better right so it's not
a defensive John Boehner but what I am
saying Pat is that I'm not that
surprised that now that he's freed from
the depraved constraints of the
political system we have I'm not that
surprised that he's saying something
like this I'm also not surprised because
he's accepting money for working as an
advisor to a marijuana company you know
that always helps a little bit too and
we're changing his mind so he claims was
that he had a friend who had back pain
and the friends started using cannabis
and apparently it helped him a great
deal and that for Boehner was you know
realization for him that oh this can
actually help people and it seems like
with Republicans they always have to see
it firsthand like you know Rob Portman
the senator from Ohio
he wasn't in support of gay marriage
until he found out that it was son was
gay it's like why does it have to impact
you personally for you to come around to
the right position don't you realize
can't use a little bit of empathy to
understand that other people are
experiencing this - absolutely and I
that is when we did the Pat Robertson
clip yesterday where Pat Robertson just
seemed perplexed like only a couple
percent of the population is LGBT why is
everybody making all these changes even
though most people aren't most people
aren't LGBT well some people have
empathy and they understand that we can
do things to help others that don't
necessarily directly benefit us although
I would argue that it benefits us
broadly speaking societally yeah it's I
I wish that I still like it when a
right-winger changes their mind on a
social position right because they
change to the correct position but I
wish it didn't take knowing someone
personally in order to say oh actually
maybe I should revisit my position but
I'll take it either way
yeah and another thing about this is
that John Bainer is a chain-smoker
that's well known I know when Paul Ryan
took over a Speaker of the House he
waited like a few weeks until the office
was fumigated before he moved in there
because it just wreaked of tobacco guys
used to smoking I wonder if instead of
regulars back home you get a little bit
that wacky tabacky and yeah I have to
change his mind just because of that I
wouldn't be at all surprised I would not
be at all surprised if that was the case
all right John Boehner yes because he's
a lobbyist now yes because he's out of
office and no longer raising money for
reelection but he at least has taken the
correct position on cannabis
legalization we will follow it that's it
for today's bonus show brand-new program
tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]